Can I freely come and go between this place and the earth?  They gave it to me, but
if you want to go to college, you'll have to pay 4 years of tuition and
all that, and it's pretty tough, right?
If you want to save money, you have
to work.
If there are products of the earth
[music] If you
sell the things you buy on the earth in this world
Wonderful alchemy and exploration The
mansion is prohibited Yeah
Fiber is just a sheet ability You
might suddenly not be able to do it
Yeah Which world?  Honcho
Well, if you have 1 billion yen, you can live reasonably comfortably until you're 100 years old.
Mono Gold Coin Yossha -
Mizuha Yamano's ambition began here - In
preparation for my safe and happy old age, I
will save 2 billion yen worth of gold coins in another world
[music]